Hale everybody and welcome to a brand
new video today and be going over one of
my money makers that have been doing for
a while but just because of recent
events it is definitely worthwhile to do
it now and that is collecting more mire
fungus if we have a look at it right now
on ji tracker link will be in the
description for GU tracker their
response to remind I definitely am
useful for looking at some of the item
prices but if we look at the price right
now 883 even maybe now let's look at the
week though it's been slowly rising up
for quite a while now and this is the
highest has been at for almost half a
year or something like that so it's
definitely worthwhile doing now now
there is quite a few different ways you
can kind of go about and do this I'm
gonna show you the method that I'm doing
right now but there is a more ideal
method than this and then a couple
others that are not as efficient but you
can do it a lot of a lower level so for
the way I'm doing it in the video I'll
start off by saying I do have the more
Tana hard diaries complete if you don't
know when you have the hard diaries in
more Tana you're gonna get double the
more mire fungus every time you cast
bloom on it next up I'm going to have 50
constructions for a house portal in my
home as well as a chapel and you will
need about 66 magic I think for the
trill teleport okay so to start off I'll
just do we run showing you how I do it
and first off just gonna get a timer
coming over my time how long it takes me
and do one run so you start off in the
krill bank or the canna this Bank I
should say and we're going to do is
actually just straight up run into this
swamp I just because I think this is a
little bit quicker than running from
Edgeville to a fairy ring or something
like that and yes we run down here
I should have deposited the stamina
potion but it's not a big deal
and just got running through the gate
here now I've tested this in a couple
different ways and I found that wasting
time trying to find the triple spawn of
the logs isn't really worth it because
since you're getting double the reward
from these guys and you actually pick
them up relatively quickly see every
time I cast bloom I'm getting two
instead of one so running the extra
distance I don't think
that much worth it and since you are
going to be restoring your prayer pretty
much every time it doesn't really matter
if you're wasting prayer potions or
anything like that so yeah just spam
bloom over and over again and should
have to cast it one more time okay there
we go and from here I teleport back to
my house and I'll go ahead and heal
myself at the altar and then we're gonna
run through the trail portal which is
just communally over here and then we're
going to be banking in the cannafest
bank altogether the run takes between a
minute and 15 seconds and about one and
a half minutes for bring your timer over
here this one took about a minute and a
half so not the best but you don't have
to restore your prayer every time of
course depending on your prayer level
so after calculations if you're really
focusing in you getting runs at about
one minute 15 seconds or a minute 20 you
can get almost a mil an hour right now
and this is not the most optimized way
to do this
yeah ideal scenario would be you have a
fairy ring in your house and you just
teleport right into the swamp from there
and from there you can do about a run
every minute and if you saw a friend's
video you could see you got 1.2 1.3 mil
in this last video so yeah we'll go
ahead and do this for an hour and CC how
much money I managed to make okay guys
so we did this for about an hour and
this is what I ended up getting about
1150 more minor fungus I hope we price
check it right now it looks like it's
worth about 930 K now we did use about
have 46 hosts help or tabs which is just
25k off that let's go to the grand
exchange and we'll go ahead and just see
how much they are actually selling for
right now cuz they are on the rise and
any more that we can get for that is
just going to add to our hourly total
and once I'm done that I'll just go
ahead and show you the method I was
using until I got my construction level
250 and my magic a bit higher because I
think this is quicker than the other
method which is running from Edgeville
to the fairy ring teleport and using the
fairy ring to tell right into the swamp
but we'll have a look at the time
thereafter okay so let's go ahead and
price check it a more mire fungus
and it looks like right now it's worth
actually 845 so if we go ahead and sell
them for 844 we're looking at pretty
close to a mil of what 950 K we got in
the one hour now if you didn't have the
Diaries completed I would cut this in
about half to be honest so probably
about 4 or 500 K an hour so the diaries
are definitely worth it by far so just
before I finish this up here I'm gonna
show you the other method that you can
use to do this entire process it's a
little bit slower I find but I'd say
it's a much lower requirement you don't
need anything for the teleports all you
will need is fairytales part 2
I had to have access to the fairy ring
teleport so basically are gonna do is
teleport to edgeville and you're gonna
run all the way around here and to the
fairy ring and then you're going to go
to the code BK r BK r and once you're
there if you just run a little bit to
the west there should be a triple spot
or if you don't feel like running that
far I can just go right there - yeah
right here where this guy's doing it you
can go ahead and get three of them but
again if you have the diary completed
I'm not really sure if it's worth
running all this way and then afterwards
you just teleport back to Edgeville bank
and repeat now one other thing you have
to keep in mind is you will have to use
a charge I took of the clan wars every
couple times their recharge your prayer
unless you are willing to drink a prayer
potion which I do not believe is going
to be worth it I would just go ahead and
wait until you have the other mess
unlocked instead of drinking a prayer
potion anyway guys I hope you did enjoy
the video if you did don't forget to
toss a little like and I will see you
guys in the next video
[Music]